[Music]
thank you for joining us for another
look at persona 5 in our last video we
took a look at some of the differences
between personas 4 and 5 and if you
missed that you can find it on the
GameSpot youtube channel subscribe while
you're there you'll get all the latest
persona videos as and when we put them
out tomorrow what are we doing this time
this time around we're gonna be delving
into some of the activities you can do
in Tokyo in personifies yes so again
this is english-language gameplay and it
takes place just after we cleared the
second palace the second dungeon and you
can see there's lots of things you can
do in Tokyo obviously to up your stats
cinema so go you can go to the cinema
you make coffee you can make coffees or
coffee if you brew it obviously because
you're staying in a cafe you can brew
coffee and if you take it into the
palaces they restore some of your spe
one of the very rare items in the game
that does restore SP yes be aware of
your SP levels as you go through the
game yeah I think it's a very smart way
of reducing grind yes and kind of
kicking you out of the palaces yep so
here we're reading so obviously reading
can up your knowledge on other different
skills but if you read some magazines or
some leaflets you can unlock new areas
of tokyo's are here we've got Herod you
could well you can take some confidence
there if you want to woo them yeah if
you think they might like the glitzy
fashionable streets of Harajuku you can
take them down there you can also rent
DVDs and I've got to say shout out to
the localization because some of these
are incredible gamer cover going mikvah
and here and we're watching the X
folders and it has a character in it
called scalzi which is just perfect yeah
I've spent a lot of time watching DVDs
in this game and it's adorable cuz a
little cat Morgana the whole time making
interesting insights and observations
about each show if I also love the
Fatima goddess it's like thank you like
a really classy way of sitting there
it's after the extended session of
watching side the innovation left proper
he'll like properly poem cellphone be
like our ego I also put this one in
because this is just one this is a good
way to increase your guts both
figuratively and literally eating giant
burgers at big bang burger yes it's a
challenge
challenged and he can just have a bath
with naked men which increases your
charm and if you come back on certain
days mondays in those days improve the
effect on your charm so you get more
charm bonuses from it so one time
earlier you said it reduces grind so
what happens now is once you've
completed the palace and stolen the
treasure at the palace collapses so you
can't go back into them and grind sort
of as you did in previous personas so
they have this place which is mementos
and it's kind of like the collection
collective unconscious basically of
everyone and so what you have to do is
you have to bring the phantom thieves
together hold a meeting and you have to
decide unanimously whether to take down
a target and so all you need is because
you dip into mementos they're evil but
not evil enough to have like a mind
Palace yes they just have slightly
distorted desires it's often people
being like my boss is a bit of a jerk
yeah well you know my mom is being
really mean to me and ruining my life so
that you go in there and find these
people and this is this is what it
people will know to be like the
traditional persona experience yeah you
go up and down these kind of like
generated on the fly levels kind of
finding items and defeating enemies and
eventually come to a boss which is not
always they're not very difficult but
they offer just enough challenge for you
to not kind of like breeze your way
through it yeah and Oh what's this
Morgana is now a bus it's a cat bus
there is a very clever bit of exposition
as to why Morgana is a cat bus but
obviously because the arrow mementos
isn't exactly doesn't look the nicest
and it's quite a large area Morgana
turns into a bus to take you around and
you can nip from floor to floor yep here
we have the holdup mechanic which was
born up hold up so you get the chance to
either do an all-out attack or collect
or negotiate and collected the persona
yeah later on in the game there is a
confidant who is a politician and he can
help you with negotiating so you can
sort of say to them give me all your
money or you can ask for items which is
like if they can sometimes give you one
item but you can sometimes use it to get
I think I've gotten three items from you
or just by sort of yelling give me items
and you can also get money out of them
yeah oh so here this is an opportunity
to show off one of the cool oh yeah so
this is where I do a baton verse which
the animations for these are always so
cool like the high five and then turned
back yeah so when you when you hit a we
finish and you can you get your extra
turn you have an opportunity you can
ability you can ability unlock later on
to pass on your turn someone else
yeah exploit weaknesses further but not
only that it gives the person who you
pass the baton to like added attack and
recovery and like if you get further on
in the game and you have loads of
different enemies as loads of different
weaknesses there is so much fun to be
had by just like chaining yeah and you
just deal ridiculous it's a really
clever combo system yeah yeah built in
an RPG which is traditionally known for
having combo systems in this kind of
fashion it's really good so here is the
girl who was so the way that we find
these people in mementos is the Phantom
thieves which is the group you belong to
have a fan site the pH and people can
post on there and say if they if there's
a baddie they want taken down then they
can post their name on the fan side and
you can decide you as a team have to
decide unanimously if you'll go take him
out yes and that information report to
you by Mishima who's that one of your
confidence he is a very enthusiastic
yeah he's he's the peak fanboy and he's
kind of like running PR and mocking for
you yeah strange to think about yeah and
it's like you have this really cool
relationship with him because you don't
actually reveal who you are that you're
one of the phantom thieves but you're
constantly talking to him so there's
kind of like yeah I know you are but I'm
not gonna say it and that that
relationship develops in a really
interesting way everyone you get into
the game so this is the shadow of a girl
who was treating her boyfriend in like a
really degrading way like being uh being
horrible to him in public and just
generally degrading him but don't think
he was he was into into it yeah so it
popped up on the fan site yeah we're
here too and a lot of these cases some
of them are simple as this is the
person's name others it's like you need
to do a little bill scowl
an information-gathering before you can
figure out what the real story is
because you need to have their name and
sometimes it will just be a rumor of
someone doing something instead of this
person is doing a thing so you like may
have to go and work in the store in the
convenience yeah so you can work at the
convenience store or I did one where I
had to work in the flour store but not
just for one day you have to do it for
like a few days and then maybe your boss
will give you a bit of information or
you walk past someone on the street and
you can hear it so it's quite cool I see
here look at me exploiting them
weaknesses okay it's an interesting me
in this state when it's like a mini boss
like this you can't negotiate with them
or at least maybe just my levels weren't
high enough at a point but I'm I'm
currently like 50 hours in and I haven't
been able to negotiate with a mini boss
one of the things I like is if you lose
to these boss slash minibus style
enemies it doesn't make you restart the
whole floor or even get straight back
out it just lets you restart the battle
which is a very welcomed time-saving ya
and frustration diminishing addition to
the game yeah I see taking them out
quick smart using explain them
weaknesses of course the stylish as ever
transition transitions and XP up screens
on here is the super cool sort of
transition screen to the infiltration
look so yeah you get this every time you
go into you mementos because to get it
when you go into your palaces it tells
you how far through the dungeon you are
which is really nice because then you
can basically plan your time really
efficiently and it's also satisfying to
leave the dungeon and see how much or
how little you've done I love it I love
coming out of a dungeon and having you
all stack up in after one session like
oh you've done all this and you've got
all the way to the end of the dungeon
nice work yeah it's possible to do that
in some cases in one day although it
will take it out of you a lot if um if
you maybe don't have any SP items but
here we have a couple of the social
links I'm not havin put too much of this
in I've seen quite a bit of tighter kami
yeah yes she is a local doctor who lives
by your home and she's got an
interesting story she's kind of known to
be a bit of a quack doctor yeah which is
quite fun but you get that to spend a
lot of time with her and help her figure
things out and in return you get
specific items which are kind of built
to either help you revive regain HP in
barrel or more kind of other small
trinkets yeah so she sells really good
items the further along her you're her
confidant rank I guess if you increase
that she sells really good stuff
especially there's one accessory that
increases SP in between each turn so you
regain a little bit of SP which is super
super useful he's also one of the
characters that you can make your BAE
what can you think so I mean I'm getting
my oh I've been giving her gift I gave
her a little cactus that she liked also
what's really cool is spending time with
your conference increases your general
stats so don't feel like you have to
spend all your time doing specific stat
boosting activities if you go with the
confidence you can increase things like
taking part in those clinical trials
gives you guts I think working for
Hawaii yeah give increases your
proficiency I want to say yeah a lot of
a lot of these similar with the shops
and stuff you visit and they can double
up on the types of qualities that it
will improve for example you can study
at a place and knowledge as well as your
guts if you only order one thing yeah so
that's all for this another look at
persona 5 for more make sure of course
you subscribe to GameSpot on YouTube and
we will hopefully have some more persona
5 for you very soon
[Music]